good morning uh first let me extend a
warm welcome
to our distinguished ministers and
Chiefs of Defense thank you for joining
us at today's historic eighth meeting of
the Ukraine defense contact group and
our first in 2023 I'm Celeste Wallander
assistant secretary of defense for
International Security Affairs and I
will serve as facilitator for today's
contact group
please allow me to to now introduce
Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin to
open today's meeting Mr secretary
thanks Celeste good morning everyone
it's great to see you all at the eighth
meeting of the Ukraine defense contact
group
together we're starting a new year with
renewed resolve
to support the brave Defenders of
Ukraine
and I know that this meeting will only
strengthen our unity and our Drive
we're honored to be joined virtually
today by President zielinski of Ukraine
and so we'll hear from him in just a few
minutes
we're also joined here in person by my
good friend Ukrainian Minister of
Defense Alexi reznikov
and let me also welcome Ukraine's Deputy
Chief of Defense Lieutenant General
moishek
it's great to have all these Brave
Leaders with us let's give them all of
our honor Applause
[Applause]
now I know that everyone here was deeply
saddened
by the helicopter crash on Wednesday
just outside of Kiev
that took the lives of more than a dozen
people including Ukraine's interior
minister
so Let Me Explain express our deep
deepest condolences to our Ukrainian
friends here today
and to all of the families in mourning
after this tragic tragic crash
we're meeting at a turbulent time
but if you look around this table
you can see the resolve and the unity of
this contact group
some 50 countries have stepped up to
help Ukraine defend itself
and deter future threats
when Putin launched his Reckless and
unprovoked Invasion 11 months ago
he thought that Ukraine would just
collapse
and he thought that the world would just
look away
but Putin didn't count on the courage of
the Ukrainian people
and he didn't count on the skill of
Ukrainian military
and he didn't count on you
on everyone on screen
and around this table
but we need to keep up our momentum and
our resolve
and we need to dig even deeper
this is a decisive moment for Ukraine
in a decisive decade for the world
so make no mistake
we will support Ukraine's self-defense
for as long as it takes
now we know that Russia remains bent on
aggression and Conquest
and Russian forces have increased their
horrific attacks
killing many innocent ukrainians
we saw the cruelty of Russia's war of
choice
again just a few days ago in the city of
nepro
a Russian missile strike ripped into an
apartment building
killing at least 46 civilians
including children
the kremlin's forces continue to bombard
Ukraine cities and citizens
and Russian forces have targeted power
plants
theaters
Sports Arenas and centers of Ukrainian
history and culture
Russia's attacks are designed to break
the spirit of Ukraine
but they have failed
and the people of Ukraine have inspired
the world
and meanwhile Russia is running out of
ammunition
and it's suffering significant battle
losses
and is turning to its few remaining
partners
to resupply its tragic and unnecessary
invasion
and even Iran
and North Korea won't admit that they're
supplying Russia
just compare that to the Groundswell of
support
for free and Sovereign Ukraine
represented in this room
I'm especially proud that the United
States has greatly increased its
security assistance to Ukraine
last month the United States announced
that we will provide a patriot air
defense battery in Associated munitions
we also included Bradley infantry
fighting vehicles in other armored
vehicles in that major package of
security assistance
and today I'm pleased to announce
another major new round of U.S security
assistance that helps to meet Ukraine's
most urgent Battlefield needs
this new security assistance package is
worth up to 2.5 billion dollars
and it's one of the largest yet
it brings total U.S security assistance
to Ukraine to more than 26.7 billion
dollars since Russia's unprovoked
Invasion by its February
our new package provides even more air
defense capabilities to help Ukraine
defend its cities
and its Skies
and that includes nay Sam's munitions
and eight air defense Avenger air
defense systems
this new assistance package also help
helps meet Ukraine's urgent need for
armor and combat vehicles
so we're providing
59 more Bradleys
90 Strikers
53 M reps and 350 up armored Humvees
and this new package will also provide
thousands more rounds of artillery
so the United States remains determined
to lead
and to do our part to help Ukraine
defend itself
now the United States will also provide
Ukrainian forces with combined arms and
Joint maneuver training
this training will work in concert with
efforts by the European Union and others
and as the United States increases our
support on multiple fronts
we're also prioritizing accountability
with cooperation from the Ukrainian
forces
and we're proud to stand together with
our value valued allies and partners
to support Ukraine's self-defense
Poland has been a leader in providing
armored vehicles
in training Ukrainian forces and in
providing shelter for Ukrainian refugees
our German hosts have announced that
they will also provide a patriot air
defense system for Ukraine complementing
our own Patriot contribution
Germany will also donate martyr infantry
fighting vehicles for Ukraine
and last week Canada announced that it
would provide a nation's air defense
system to Ukraine
and that's a major investment in
Ukraine's ability to defend its Skies
France also announced a significant
donation of amx10 light tanks
in many European countries have
announced their own training initiatives
as a part of the eu's military
assistance mission to Ukraine
these announcements especially on air
defense donations
are direct results of this contact group
and today we will continue our important
work together
our Ukrainian friends will discuss the
situation on the ground in their most
urgent needs especially air defense and
armored vehicles
and then we'll discuss our complementary
training initiatives
we'll also get an update on ways to
energize the industrial base
coming out of the national armaments
director's meeting
and finally we'll hear from many of the
countries here today about your ongoing
support for Ukraine's self-defense
ladies and gentlemen this is a crucial
moment
Russia is regrouping
recruiting and trying to re-equip
this is not a moment to slow down
it's a time to dig deeper
the Ukrainian people are watching us
the Kremlin is watching us
in history is watching us
so we won't let up
and we won't waver in our determination
to help Ukraine defend itself from
Russia's Imperial aggression
now we're honored today to have a
special guest with US president
zielinski of Ukraine
his leadership and Grace Under Fire had
inspired the Ukrainian people
and everyone in this room
he embodies the spirit of Ukraine
and as he told our Congress last month
Ukraine is Alive and Kicking
so Mr President
let me turn it over to you to share your
message with this contact group and
thank you so much for joining us over to
you Mr President
thank you very much
secondary
very important and thank you for
condolences in this package of
supporting us thank you
ladies and gentlemen we are participants
of the victory makers College
and
grateful to you
for the achieved unity and this dialogue
and cooperation format we see the
results on the battlefield in Ukraine
thank you
on the battlefield against our common
enemy and I believe that our Unity will
only become stronger with every new
Rammstein
but do we have a lot of time no Terror
does not allow for discussion
the terror which burns sitting after
City becomes insolent when I feel that
that Defenders of Freedom run out of
weapons against it
the war started by Russia does not allow
delays and I and I can thank you
hundreds of times and it will be
absolutely just in fear given all that
we have already done but
hundreds of thank you are not hundreds
of talents
all of us can use thousands of words in
discussions but I cannot put words
instead of gods that are needed against
Russian Artillery or instead of
instead of that anti-aircraft missile
that I needed to protect people from
Russian airstrikes and I am truly
grateful to all of you for the weapons
you have provided every unit helps to
see our people from Terror at times
remains a rational level
we have to speed up time must become our
comfort level
just like air defense and artillery
armored vehicles and tanks which we are
negotiating about review
and we actually will make the victory
ladies and gentlemen this is the first
time I'm addressing you in such format
and I'm addressing you not as Ministers
of military we are houses but as
Ministers of Defense defense of
everything that makes our world free
civilized and I am addressing you those
who swore the values of freedom and who
remember the world your parents dreamed
of for you and I'm addressing you those
who themselves bring off
a football for their children
those dreams
you do not want to allow such a world
order where hatred will rule your
parents could not want a kind of world
for you you would not want such a wall
for your children but this
this exactly such a world order that
Russia speaks all of us not only for
your brain but for the whole world
Russia wants the power to destroy
Nations and they talk openly about it in
Moscow yes Russia wants to destroy a law
and Universal human values and there are
some troops
by their actions on the territory of
Ukraine are fighting just for these
in order to Teach the World to hate
Russia is concentrating its forces
last forces trying to convince everyone
that hatred can be stronger than the
world
that is why you and I
have to spit out we have to do it we
must act as fast as a father or mother
who sees their child as a son or
daughter who sees their their parents
need immediate help it is about what
kind of world people will live in
people who dream love and hope they hope
that that freedom will be protected for
Ukraine for
for all humor for each and every
coalition's country it is about people
who believe that evil and hatred will
always lose
the Kremlin must lose
lettuce
you are stronger people of powerful
countries and I know your bravery and I
appreciate everything you have done and
are doing now
foreign
Russian people of of any power you can
start this policy today it is in your
power to make a Rammstein of terms
not to bargain about different numbers
of tense but to open a principle Supply
that will stop
evil
and we also come at your next Gatherings
will go down in history
F-16 and long range missiles it is in
your power to guarantee such artillery
and any aircraft that will crush
terrible it is in your power to make the
name
decisions
keep
accurately
just like our heroes on the front lines
glory to all of our soldiers Soldiers
and Sailors sergeants and former offices
and Generals and think each and every
one of you who defends freedom
following
[Applause]
thank you Mr President I hope you know
that we will continue to stand up for
Ukraine's right to defend itself
and we'll continue to stand up for the
principal
that borders may not be redrawn by force
and we will continue to stand up for an
open world of rules rights and
responsibilities again thank you for
being here today
now as always we're going to pause for a
minute while our friends in the media
depart
thank